dominating the media has been the sudden
sharp cooling in relations between the
American and French presidents after
their rather awkward meeting in Paris on
the 100th anniversary of the World War
one armistice last night Donald Trump
went on the attack on Twitter his target
again Emmanuel macron let's find out
what's really going on from our Paris
correspondent our teaser Charlotte
dubitzky joining us here on the program
their relationship Charlotte had been
termed a bromance but evidently these
days they don't seem to be well kissing
and hugging quite as much as they were
well that's right and world headlines
seem to be in shock and dismay over the
fact that this bromance seems to have
fizzled out so spectacularly this is the
bromance being over between Trump and
Matt Guan let's have a look at now some
of the international headlines about the
end of that relationship some saying the
souring of the bromance the end of the
bromance some also suggesting it's the
end of the friendship that's how the
world press are reacting to it well what
about here in France well some of the
headlines here that if you can see it
this is from La Figaro and it says the
return to Washington
Trump castigates the protectionism of
France or of Paris then here we have in
la Parisienne
it basically says Trump makes fun of
macron says the Year present American
president as rallied on Twitter against
the side of the popularity of his former
French friend and also talked about his
opposition to the European army this one
here in Lomond also talking about that
European army suggesting that Merkel and
macron are in solidarity against and
facing Trump so that some of the
headlines here in France were what spark
that her age on Twitter it was this but
it was Germany in World Wars 1 and 2 how
did that work out for France they were
starting to learn German in Paris before
the u.s. came along pay for NATO or not
France makes it very hard for the u.s.
to sell it
wines into France and charges big
tariffs not fair must change the problem
is that a manual suffers from a very low
approval rating in France 26% and an
unemployment rate of almost 10% make
France great again well that was the
tirade on Twitter of Donald Trump and
why was it like that because for so long
it seems to have been hugs it seems to
have been kisses sort of caught off
attention lovely remarks and glances at
each other but it seems it was all down
to the interview that Emmanuel macron
gave last week about the possibility of
a European into European army imported
hot bellies or beer we need the Europe
can defend itself long ago without
depending only on the United States in a
way that exhibits great to sovereignty
security well it's not the first time of
course that macron has spoken out
against Trump and been in stark
disagreement with his policies let's not
forget when Trump came first into power
he decided that he was going to leave
the Paris climate Accord agreements this
is what Matt Cohen had to say about that
navigate I consider it a mistake for the
US and its people and a mistake for the
future of our planet and then perhaps
more seriously and more recently there
was the fact that the u.s. decided that
it would withdraw from the Iranian
nuclear accord something France and
Makhan was incredibly unhappy about
Trump has lost the battle ultimately no
one followed his decisions and now we
have to make good on fulfilling our
obligations well as you may recall the
Trump seemed to let all of those
disagreements between the two slide but
not this time so what's the difference
now with this in regards to the idea of
the creation of a European army well it
could be down to plain old cash yes just
that as we
Trump is a businessman and he would be
very unhappy with the idea of seeing
money that could go into American
pockets and go elsewhere so it seems
that's what this is coming down to for
him the idea of losing money is
essentially to be treated like a capital
offense and of course there's also the
fact that McCune could incite others to
do the same and follow him in fact he
already has with Angela Merkel the
Chancellor of Germany saying that she
fully supports this idea so in fact what
trumps perhaps trying to do is in short
stop a revolution
you